my dad was
Inspector Gadget growing up he always
had the latest technology the latest toy
he liked to play with it learn about it
and he would teach myself and my brother
and then my mom was a preschool teacher
which is something that I ended up going
into I volunteered in classroom starting
from when I was in fourth grade and then
with myself I was a total theater nerd
and a total performance nerd I'm Jenny
Brown and this is my journey to becoming
a Google developer advocate
[Music]
started off wanting to go into the
mental health space and becoming a
therapist because I had worked in
classrooms for so long and I really
wanted to go into the non-profit space
and help provide really valuable
services for companies and Educational
Systems that were sort of struggling
with funding and resources so I studied
psychology in school and then got a job
in Tech sales right afterwards from
there I got recruited by Google and I
went into entry-level sales here and
that sort of transformed into training
and helping create teams and skill up
teams and then
video became a side project that I did
and that really
scratched that performance itch and
everything has really come together
where I'm doing videos now that are
enablement based and are training based
and educationally based so it's just a
really nice unintentional full circle I
think a really cool part of making
technology accessible
and a really critical part of that
journey is understanding that there's a
lot of people who aren't Tech native
creating content that's a little bit
more inclusive and a little bit more
Mindful and uses fun analogies and
metaphors to really
paint a better picture of technology is
something that I really like doing
making content that empowers or helps
other people whether it's to find a job
or do something in an entirely different
Arena of someone's life that makes me so
happy I studied psychology and religion
and now I work in engineering at Google
and my job is primarily on camera
that is a dream I didn't know I had
could not have anticipated
any part of this for myself it's still
really cool and I'm grateful to be here
foreign
[Music]